welcome back to Las Vegas now Seoul
Mexican Cocina is cooking up all the
good stuff I wish you guys could smell
it in here it smells amazing I'm joined
by Chef Samantha de Leon thank you so
much for being here thank you for having
me so you guys are located in the Forum
Shops a great location you're serving
brunch now tell us a little bit about
the restaurant yeah so we're Baja
inspired it's a little more Elevated
Cuisine uh from you know Mexican cooking
there's a lot of flavors and it's very
you know rustic cooking but plating it
in a better version than you can say
this looks beautiful the pleating is
incredible I was eyeing is that a french
toast over here what is it not a friend
okay what is it that is our souffle
Carlita which is a bread pudding I love
a good breakfast I mean this looks so
good you have a burrito over here but we
got to get cooking tell us what yes we
do we are making Kobe steak and eggs are
so amazing cracking the eggs Amanda over
there how I felt about making eggs and I
got too nervous like that she has to do
it because she's the professional and
I'm just going to admire because you
even got the crack down perfectly I mean
honestly it looks like an easy job but
it's not so we're starting with our eggs
here we're starting with our eggs I'm
gonna put a little bit of butter in
there okay everything is better with
butter everything is better with butter
and your food truly is authentic it's a
little bit lighter in my mind like you
kind of feel less guilty if you eat the
whole bread pudding right oh yeah so we
even have like a
if you don't feel like attacking the
whole thing you could just kind of get
half of it going on so we're gonna let
that sit okay
um I love sunny side we're gonna leave
it sunny side and then we'll have some
steak in the oven okay oh you you
prepped hard today this is the Kobe
steak right this is the Kobe steak okay
uh Japanese cow this looks good this um
is like living the life over here better
than me you know these cows get massage
they get they're like grass-fed they
have like a wonderful life so you guys
have the good stuff slicing over here I
also see some champagne and drinks off
to the side you guys offer mimosas and
fun cocktails too right yeah we offer
mimosas this is our rainbow Mimosa with
a bunch of different mixtures uh we have
our pomegranate grapefruit Orange
um it looks very delicious so many
options here with this and we have to
wrap up pretty quickly here so I know
this is still cooking so so we will save
this and post it on social media so you
can see the final product and I promise
you want to check it out because it
smells delicious already so be sure to
go check out uh you give me this so
Mexican Cocina at The Forum Shops in
Caesars Palace thank you so much for
being here Chef's the man thank you for
having me I gotta come visit you got to
teach me how to make eggs of course all
right Mercedes